ich war mal wieder in den deutschen
youtube fans unterwegs und hat dort
videos gesehen wie beispielsweise xxl
glücksrad duell mit vitamine in mainz
danach musste ich erst mal zum ohrenarzt
geräte bei juli featuring angelucci
kritik
[Musik]
genau alle diktator tat 8
özdemir gestern sudan handschuhe sind
okay aber diesen ganzen kram es erstmal
beiseite er den deutschen youtube trends
auf platz eins befindet sich nämlich
gerade das video von sky base standard
skill featuring a janda auf fisch music
video und als thumbnail wie er mit einem
gleiter durch tötet hours fliegt bevor
wir uns das video anschauen schauen wir
uns erstmal den youtube kanal von dem
user standard skill an
er macht tatsächlich erlebt tatsächlich
100% fortner videos hoch als erlebt hat
wirklich jeden tag ein neues portner
gameplay video hoch ich hab's noch
selber panne gucken weil er wirklich
news direkt raus haut er sagt direkt ok
epic games hat jetzt das neue
hinzugefügt dienstags also erhält seine
community wirklich auf dem aktuellsten
stand was wird heute um 22 uhr im
vorteil passiert mein gott der drache
ist auf jeden fall schon mal nicht gut
drauf zu sprechen ich weiß nicht wie man
so energiegeladen in den video gehen
kann weil ich selber habe mir meine
hyperaktiven phasen aber diese augen
also er witze halt wirklich so und hat
so richtig wollte auf diesem game war ja
ich auf jeden fall übertrieben wenn
leute richtig bock haben die videos zu
machen
wenn leute allerdings auf krassen
schnitt stehen oder bearbeitungs gilt
oder irgendwelche einblendungen oder was
weiß ich was passiert hier gar nicht
also es ist wirklich die ganze zeit
seine käme hier ohne irgendwie ein
schatten allein oder sowas ist einfach
mit hintergrundmusik und er spielt
wirklich vorteile und man erkennt auch
in eigentlich nie so wirklich sein mund
ist aber natürlich auch nicht das thema
auf seinem kanal muss man ganz klar so
sagen er ist einfach ein guter spieler
und ford bringt den leuten was bei und
hatten nun als dankeschön für seine
community für das starke wachstum
wahrscheinlich einen song rausgehauen
fordert chance kaymer ist standard skill
featuring a janda wenn youtuber musik
machen beziehungsweise allgemein
anfangen zu singen
finde ich es immer so ein bisschen
bedenklich beziehungsweise jeder erstmal
na ja so ein bisschen voreingenommen
rein weil man weil das ja nicht der
hauptfokus eigentlich auf dem kanal ist
deswegen bin ich auch dir sehr gespannt
ich würde allerdings sagen bevor ich
jetzt auf play drücken
wir schauen wir uns erst mal ein paar
kommentare an die unter dem video
gepostet wurden wie kann sowas in platz
eins trends seien quatsch was ist das
für ein aids standard skill ich mag dich
aber das ist quatsch wir alle kritik
kommentare gelöscht hat da waren so
viele kommentare mit queens über 200
likes oder so hatten ich persönlich mag
den song nicht weil er mich nervt und so
zurückgeblieben wirkt dieser dreck song
ist auf platz 1 bei standard skills zug
in die geworden wegen fordert lächerlich
früher gta warst du aber jetzt bist du
keller musikalisch einfach nur müll man
merkt also direkt dass viele leute die
standard skill vielleicht gar nicht
kennen und nicht wissen was er sonstwo
hochlädt em und den song war sie einfach
nur ein platz eins der deutschen youtube
gesehen haben sich dem song angehört
haben und den song komplett scheiße
fanden und das dementsprechend auch
kommentiert haben muss den youtuber
standards gilt auf jeden fall ein
bisschen in schutz nehmen will ist quasi
fordert youtuber zockt hauptsächlich auf
seinem kanal und will nur seine als of
community ein geschenk geben indem er
diesen song gemacht hat es ist quasi
nicht für die allgemeinheit bestimmt
sondern nur für seine primären zuschauer
hat jetzt wegen ist es natürlich mehr
als verständlich dass hier sehr viele
leute die vielleicht älter sind und
einfach sich youtube trends mal
angeschaut haben und dann diesen sommer
platz eins gesichert einfach gedacht
haben hey da hat er schon musikalisch
einfach nur müll
das kommentiere ich das soll er wissen
allerdings werde ich jetzt noch den song
reagieren und eine eigene meinung dazu
bilden also was man direkt sagen muss
herr standard skill kauft ihr bitte ein
größeres bettlaken also man sieht direkt
dass es so eine kombination wird
wahrscheinlich auch fortnight in diesen
aufnahmen
es hat sich bisher noch so ein typ
ein battle royale mache ich zu meiner
hast aufgabe meine mutter merkte
hausaufgaben sie sagte ich finde es
lustig dass er sagt meine mutter nervt
mit hausaufgaben
er sieht halt nicht so aus als würde die
schule gehen check check komme mit einem
tag eine chance für jeden seiner star
produziert ist das video gar nicht mal
so schlecht dass ich hier dieser bus in
sonnen fortnight partybus verwandelte
schon ganz cool
jetzt aber erstmal jetzt haben wieder so
ingame aufnahmen habe ich denke es auf
den punkt durch meine freunde noch
einmal von play sie dann ist das aus mit
ich finde
den ganzen sommer so ein bisschen mehr
abstimmen können ich hab selber keine
ahnung von produzieren ich bin mir das
neutrale letzter zeit selber so ein
bisschen weil ich mich in der richtung
was ein bisschen weiterbilden will
selber so ein bisschen elektronische
musik produzieren et cetera pp nicht was
singen angeht sondern wirklich nur das
produzieren von tracks aber ich also die
stimme im vergleich zu dem zudem biete
dem punkt wird meine träume noch einmal
von clay sie dann ist das hört sich
nicht gut abgemischt an allerdings das
ist ja auch kein richtiges musik
meisterwerk soll es ja auch nicht sein
sondern es ist ja nur einfach sondern
geschenk für zwischendurch besuchen
[Musik]
er haut
das videos also bisschen crazy das muss
man schon sagen also er ist ja ich weiß
nicht wie alt er ist also ich will mich
jetzt auch nicht irgendwie unbeliebt
machen seiner community wer sieht schon
ein bisschen älter und nicht aus es geht
jetzt gerade auf die 30 zu er kann auch
am bad liegen keine ahnung was aber dann
ist eine sonderklasse mit solchen
kindern
na ja ach du scheiße das sind das ist
das in hamburg trikot gott also soweit
ich das jetzt richtig zusammenfassen
kann er singt darüber dass er übel
süchtig ist nach ford leid denkt die
ganze zeit daran seine umwelt verwandelt
sich auch in einer gewissen form schon
sofort also sein bus der dazu diesem
partybus wird beispielsweise besser in
der schule und denkt auch nur an das
neue fortnight update der lehrer
bestellte ihn an die tafel er weiß keine
antwort verwandelt den lehrer hat
zusammen lama zusammen fortnight lama
und dann brechen alle außen wollen
fordert spiel und die lehrer drucken
jetzt so zettl und auf den draufsteht
fortnight verboten ich hätte halt viel
viel cooler gefunden wenn das ganze so
ein bisschen glaubwürdiger gemacht
worden wäre zum beispiel er geht nicht
mehr zur schule sondern geht in die uni
oder dass er vielleicht gar nicht der
hauptcharakter ist sondern irgendein
anderer kleiner junge und dann stellt
man nachher eine entwicklung da das er
dann standard skill wird oder so als
lehrer hätte ich an standards gilt
stelle auch er so 50 60 jährige etwas
ältere grimmige hre personen genommen
anstatt zu 20 jährige die einfach eine
brille und ein hemd an haben aber wir
hören wir weiter kein tag ohne fortnight
unverstellt reicht weder geld beiseite
doch genehmigt
denn ich doch klasse die kohle
blütenregen libeskind und fragen ob ich
das verstehe ich ja ehrlich gesagt nicht
also jetzt anfordert allgemeinen ich
habe fordert zwar selber schon fünf
sechs sieben mal auf meinem kanal
hochgeladen und ich meinen jeder weiß
ich bin der beste spieler so gehe ich
übrigens auch immer aus meiner wohnung
raus also wenn irgendwann tim weg ist
oder so dann nutze ich nicht die tür
oder suchen den weg oder allerdings weiß
ich noch nicht genau was es bringt sich
skins zu kaufen
man hat dadurch ja keinen vorteil im
game oder eine ahnung wie ich das falsch
sehe ich habe mir selber schon passt ins
gekauft das ist ja aber eigentlich nur
so um den andern leuten zu zeigen hey
ich kann das spiel und ich kann so gut
gespielt so auf dass es mir wert ist
dass ich jetzt den euro investieren
damit ich in gamer anders aussehen habe
was mir aber eigentlich nichts bringen
ich weiß nicht ob ich in diesem video
allgemein schon gesagt habe aber das
soll überhaupt nicht beleidigend sein
gegenüber irgendwelchen fortnight
spielern seiner community oder ihm
selbst ich schaue mir selber oft welche
von seinen videos an einfach um auf dem
neuesten stand zu sein was epic games
jetzt raus
und das ist vielleicht die
verschwörungstheorien gibt und wie eine
neue waffe funktioniert also heißt es
auf youtube wirklich mit einer meiner
liebsten orte kennen eben natürlich im
riverside
das ist meine absolute lieblingsstadt
oberin allerdings hätte ich da nicht so
schlau heraus doch erst bei der hälfte
der jackpot
ganz im ernst ich weiß nicht was die
sich bei dem musikvideo gedacht haben er
läuft durch diesem schuljahr dieser
junge hier kommt zum beispiel gar nicht
irgendwie dran vorbei also ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht was die aufgabe
jetzt wahrscheinlich wurde ihnen einfach
gesagt hey
lauft einfach um mich rum also macht das
ganze bild ehrlich gesagt sehr unsauber
finde ich toll aber wahrscheinlich so
dafür stehen haye fordert update raus
hier ist die lutzi los alles laufen
linksruck kreuz quer rückwärtssalto
[Musik]
also das ist cool mit diesen animationen
inzwischen durch das aber auch das
einzige was irgendwie animiert wurde es
ist ein übergang zwischen wir sind in
der schule und es ist langweilig und
dann wird standard skill quasi der
lehrer der vorhin noch selbst bei den
schülern sei es irgendwie um zeigt denen
jetzt dinge die es im fordert gibt wie
ich es hätte man noch nicht was skyways
ist er zeigt gerade auf mich und sagt
ich bin nicht eigentlich der beste
spieler skyways ist das irgendwie sowas
wie wenn man sich einmal ganz oben baut
und dann
im kampf macht man eine festung in der
luft baba schießt man sich gegenseitig
in asche
falls sie jetzt ja alles richtig
verstanden hat sollte müssen darum gehen
er befreit die schüler aus dem
unterricht und zeigt den haye mit
fortnight habt ihr spaß in der schule zu
hause
und im chemieunterricht also
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist schon sehr komisch wie bereits
zu beginn gesagt er will ja auch glaube
ich gar nicht in diese musik szene damit
jetzt einbrechen und will den leuten
zeigen hey ich bin zwar glichen fordert
youtube wir damit jetzt der reichweite
aufgebaut und jetzt werde ich musik
machen das ist glaube ich
beziehungsweise hoffe ich nicht eine
einstellung weil dafür ist es sieht echt
nicht geil aber als sondern man also man
kann es nicht hätten es ist jetzt nicht
das er sagt hey ich bin katja glaser
witz und das wird mein neuer song und
ich habe den fed angekündigt und den
gibt's auch bei spotify oder scheiße den
gibt's wirklich bei spotify
ich glaube aber ehrlich gesagt dass das
hier er sonst spaß dingels und das merkt
man natürlich auch daran dass sie sich
dann alle hier mit nerf ganz abschließen
und das hauptsächliche cast sage ich mal
auf den kleinen kinder aus der schule
besteht wahrscheinlich einfach gesagt
hey ich will uns sorgen machen irgendwas
mit vorteilen einer community
zurückgeben hat noch einen fan treffen
mit den leuten gemacht keine ahnung ich
finde eigentlich in school aktion
[Musik]
damit endet das video
es ist vorbei jetzt einigkeit noch etwas
kann man abschließend zu dem song sagen
er ist nicht geil ich würde es nicht
hören
ich würde mir kein zweites mal anhören
ich würde nicht im auto hören und ich
würde auch keinen daumen hoch geben auch
keinen daumen runter weil ich schätze
die arbeit und die geste an sich viele
leute haben mir gesagt luca das ist voll
der crash song reagiert einmal drauf
guckt mal ein paar kommentare daran
haben kann ich nur recht geben der song
ist halt aber wirklich gerade platz 1 in
den deutschen youtube trends er hat zwei
millionen aufrufe nach einem tag
standard skill ehrlich gesagt wirklich
respekt für eine aktive community im
falls saison einen sprung in die
musikindustrie sein soll ist er
definitiv missglückt song fire ich jetzt
gar nicht mal so krass ich finde es
allerdings
also es war abzusehen dass irgendwann
mehr fortnight songs kommen werden hier
die ngz hat er auch schon ein gemacht
jeder spieler ist mein team sammelte mit
einem horch zeichnen will
damit gibt es energies natürlich anderes
level deshalb deshalb krass ich weiß
nicht wie gefällt euch der sorgen hat im
spiel überhaupt worten erkennt ihr den
youtuber standard skill überhaupt ich
kannte ihn zum beispiel vor dem bei der
ganzen fordert wenn er überhaupt nicht
finde ich aber macht sehr coole videos
grüße gehen auf jeden fall raus ja
lasten like da wenn euch meine reaction
gefallen hat schreibt die kommentare auf
was ich vielleicht zwanzig mal reagieren
soll
[Musik]